>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Good morning.
>> Good morning.
>> Lee Ann Potter: I am so
impressed with how you guys came
into this room and where so
quiet and such good listeners.
So, thank you for that.
Really appreciate it.
>> You're welcome.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Oh,
and thank you for that.
So, I'm Leanne Potter.
I direct educational outreach
here at the Library of Congress
and I have five things I
get to say this morning.
Do you guys ever, when you
have to remember five things,
do you have any special
ways of remembering?
What do you do?
>> [Inaudible audience response]
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Yeah, I could do that.
Yeah, if I could sing
I would do it that way.
But no, you don't want that.
So, what I tend to do is, I tend
to put initials next to what I--
that was bad, I won't
do that again--
I put initials next
to what I have to say.
Do you see those letters up there?
Read my letters.
Just at the very top.
>> TW, THW.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah, so
this is what I have to do.
TW, THW. T, first thing
I want to do is T. I want
to thank my colleagues
Karen and Monica and Sasha
for making this morning happen.
I also want to thank
my friends who work
in our multimedia division
for filming this.
And Shawn who's taking
pictures this morning.
So that's my first T, thank you.
Second letter, remember what it was?
>> W.
>> Lee Ann Potter: W. Any
idea what words arts with W?
>> What.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
What's good, but no,
this one's better, this is welcome.
So, I get to welcome.
Who do you suppose
I want to welcome?
>> Us.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah, I want
to welcome you guys so I'm going
to welcome the third
and fourth graders
from Plummer Elementary
School in Washington DC,
and their teachers
and their chaperones.
How about that?
So, you've been welcomed
and it's on film.
Yeah, all right would you
remember what my next letter was?
>> T.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
Yeah, you guys are good.
Okay so I had a thank
you, I had a welcome,
what do you suppose the T is for?
>> [Inaudible audience response]
>> Lee Ann Potter: Yeah,
another thanks you.
I thank a lot.
Yeah, so who else should
I be thanking?
>> Teachers, us?
Everybody.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's right,
I'm going to thank our
friends at Everybody Wins DC.
They are responsible for getting
you guys here today and making sure
that you're going to
go home with a copy
of the book you're going
to hear about today.
Okay, so, like yeah
that deserves a clap.
[ Applause ]
Oh, good alright so
that was T and W and T
and remember what the next one was?
>> B, W, oh H.
>> Lee Ann Potter: H. Yeah H.
Any idea what starts with H?
>> Help.
>> Lee Ann Potter: What's
a really good kind of,
what's a very what's a very
pleasant word that starts with H?
>> Hi, how are you?
>> Lee Ann Potter: When you have a
birthday, what does somebody say?
>> Happy.
>> Lee Ann Potter: That's right so
it's sort of like a happy birthday
but it's a happy anniversary.
So, it's happy anniversary,
twenty-five years
that an organization that is
also an organization I want
to thank this morning.
So, I'm saying happy anniversary
to our friends responsible
for the book award that is being
celebrated today with our author.
The organization is The Children's
Africana Book Awards Program.
Their initials are KABA, so we're
we are happy anniversary-ing them
this morning.
Is that a word?
>> No.
>> Lee Ann Potter:
It's not really a word,
let's just say we are wishing
them a happy anniversary
and we're welcoming them.
Awesome and you've got
bookmark for everybody.
Fabulous.
[ Inaudible audience response ]
Awesome the Museum of African art
on Saturday and everybody's going
to get a bookmark to take home
with this year's award winners.
Okay do you remember
what my last letter was?
>> W.
>> Lee Ann Potter: It was
another W. You are good.
You're good at this.
See, this is, you're going
to remember things
like I remember things.
I like that.
So, my next letter was W and
this time it's our welcome
and it's our welcome to
our very special author,
and guess what letter her
last name starts with?
>> A W.
>> Lee Ann Potter: W, so
it was really convenient.
So, Emily come on up here.
I'm going to tell you guys
about Emily, our author.
>> Emily Williamson: Hi guys.
[ Applause ]
>> Lee Ann Potter: Got close.
That's great.
Alright, so this is the book
that Emily's going to talk about,
but I want to tell you a
little bit about Emily first.
You know how you guys are
in third and fourth grade?
>> Yeah.
>> Lee Ann Potter: Okay so if
Emily, Emily still goes to school.
Okay Emily has been going
to school for a long time
because she really likes
school and if we were
to say what grade Emily was
in, Emily's like in grade 22.
Seriously.
So, she finished high
school, she went to college,
she studied art history, she
studied architecture and now,
she must like the letter
A, because she's studying--
>> Author.
>> You guys are good.
I didn't even think of that.
She's an author but she
is studying archaeology,
she is studying anthropology
and archaeology
and she's going to
tell you about that.
She's also been very interested in a
country in West Africa called Ghana.
Do any of you know
where Ghana is located?
I want to say, I taught geography
for a long time and I want
to show you a really cool trick.
So, I want you guys to take your
left hand and sort of drop it down
and try to bend your
knuckle at your thumb.
That's it you got it.
Okay so when you do that to your
hand, your hand sort of looks
like the continent of Africa.
Okay, isn't that cool?
So, if you look at, oh yeah
it sort of does, that's cool,
my left-hand sore it looks like
Africa and if you look right
where your knuckle is
where you try to bend it,
that's where Ghana is located.
So, the next time you look at
a map of Africa you'll know
that Ghana is located
right where your knuckle is
if your hand were the
continent of Africa.
Does that work for you?
Okay, I got a lot of weird ways
to remember things, but anyway,
so we're going to learn a little
bit about Ghana in West Africa today
and we are so happy that you
are here with us and I'm going
to hand my microphone over to you
and thank you boys and girls again
for being such good visitors to the
Library of Congress this morning.
>> Emily Williamson:
And I think actually,
I don't even need a microphone.
I actually have a built-in
microphone today.
Exactly, so thank you so much
for that generous introduction.
Thank you so much to the Library
of Congress for having me,
thank you to the Bab of Book
Awards Organizational Committee
and everyone else who helped make
this happen, I really appreciate it.
It's so wonderful to be
here with all of you today.
So, in English, my name
is Emily, but did you know
that I also have a Ghanaian name?
>> No.
>> Emily Williamson: Yeah, so it
begins with H. Can anyone guess?
>> [Children answering
in unison] Happy.
>> Emily Williamson: Close,
I actually have a friend
in Ghana whose name is Happy,
but this is another name.
This is an Arabic name.
It's Habiba, yes has anyone
heard of that name before?
>> No.
>> Emily Williamson: So,
in Arabic it means beloved
or someone who's very
loving or caring okay.
So, and then I also want to
teach you another word in Hausa
so the community that I worked
with and the students that I worked
with in Ghana to create this
book, they speak the language
of Hausa has anyone ever
heard of that before?
>> No.
>> Emily Williamson: Okay, I do
speak it a little bit and I wanted
to start today by teaching you
a word in Hausa that begins
with S. [Inaudible
children guessing] close,
close so it's sannu
[phonetic spelling].
Okay so I'll say it and then
you could repeat after me.
sannu.
>> Sannu.
>> Emily Williamson: Can
anyone guess what that means?
[ Inaudible children guessing ]
Close. I mean, it's a greeting.
What's the first greeting
you might say to somebody?
>> Hello.
>> Emily Williamson:
Hello, exactly sannu.
So, when I say sannu to you, you
respond, and you say, yowah sannu.
>> Yowha sannu.
>> Emily Williamson: Okay, so
I'll say sannu, and you say,
>> Yowha sannu.
>> Emily Williamson: Perfect,
so now whenever you meet,
if you get a chance to meet any
of these students from Ghana,
you can say, I'll say sannu,
and you can say to them,
>> Yowha sannu.
>> Emily Williamson:
Wow that's awesome.
That is great okay, so my name is
Emily Habiba and I have a, yes,
I have gone to, I don't
know, I'm in grade 22.
Something like and I have a
background in architecture
and I'm a designer and an
illustrator and a writer
and right now I'm in a program,
it's a PHD program on anthropology.
Does anyone know what
anthropology is?
>> No.
>> Emily Williamson: So, it's
the study of cultures and humans
and how we experience the world.
So, my job is to get to
know how other people think
and how they see the world
and so for me, writing
and illustrating children's stories
has been a really wonderful way
to do that because it's a way
of understanding local issues
and connecting with mostly students
like you guys over in Ghana.
So, I've been doing this since 2002,
and yeah, long, long, long, time ago
and started working and writing
and illustrating children's stories
with students there and
then I just keep going back.
I can't get enough.
I love the kids and I love
drawing and writing with them and,
so we've been putting together a
number of workshops over the years
and one of the outcomes
of the workshops was creating this
book called Gizo-Gizo which I want
to talk to you about today.
So, Gizo-Gizo, you guys are going to
get to know another word in Hausa.
Do you know what that might mean?
>> Gizo.
>> Emily Williamson: What do you
what do you think Gizo-Gizo means?
>> Spider.
>> Emily Williamson: Yes, exactly.
So, it means spider in the language
of Hausa okay and so the origins
of this story came out of me, so
I was talking to a lot of adults
and I was trying to understand
what the issues were about water.
So how to collect water, how to
store water, how to clean water
in these communities and I'll show
you some pictures in a little bit.
And you know, I was like, but I want
to know what the kids think and,
so I went to a school and
I asked all of the kids.
I said, what are some
of the issues here?
And one little boy raised his
hand and he said, you know,
my family hasn't had any
clean water for over two weeks
because a mining company up
in the North had polluted all
of the water all the
way down to his village.
So, they had no clean water and they
had to walk for miles to be able
to get clean water to drink.
And then all of a sudden,
another kid raised their hand
and they said oh, the same
thing here my family too.
We haven't had any
clean water for so long
and then another child raised
his hand and said the same thing
and then before I knew it,
all of the kids were talking
about this and, so we decided
to write and illustrative story
to be able to tell the
adults, what was going on
and to hopefully find
a way to fix it.
So, this story is fictional
but based upon real issues
and real local concerns
that the kids had.
So, it's a way that
the kids could kind
of give voice to their concerns.
So, you can also, you guys
can also think about, okay,
like what are some, what are some
things that I'm frustrated with?
Or that I really love that might
translate into some kind of story?
Okay, so I'm going to read it in
a little bit but first I just want
to show you some pictures
of Ghana okay.
Does anybody have any
questions so far?
Okay so, we know where Africa is?
>> Yeah.
>> Emily Williamson: Yeah, I'm just
going to point it out just in case.
So again, the left hand.
>> It's right there!
>> Emily Williamson: Yeah.
Okay so now we're a
little bit closer.
[Inaudible audience comments] yep
so here's the left upside-down
left hand, again right?
And Ghana is right here okay?
So, it's the yellow
country right here.
So, there's a big coastline and
where this story takes place,
it's in a town called
Cape Coast Ghana
and it's right along the coast.
So, what might you think would be
in a story if it's along the coast?
Yeah?
>> Water.
>> Emily Williamson: Water, okay
great yeah so there might be water
in this story and you might be able
to tell that too from the cover.
>> It might be spider webs.
>> Emily Williamson: There might
be spider webs, absolutely.
>> I think it will be water because
of how close it is to the water.
>> I think it [children
speaking all at once]
>> Emily Williamson: Yeah so here
we go, oh you know about fufu.
I think spider really likes fufu.
We'll get to that.
Okay, so this is a picture of
Cape Coast from the tallest,
tallest hill looking down at the
city, looking out across the ocean,
and so you can see
another big church there
and there's a big slave
castle along the coast too.
But you can see that these are some
of the houses that
the people live in.
And here we're along
the coast, right?
So, there are a lot
of fishing boats.
>> Why are their boats like that?
They don't sail?
>> Emily Williamson: And then this,
so the full name of the book is,
Gizo-Gizo a Tale from
the Zongo Lagoon.
So, this is actually the lagoon
that they were writing about.
It's pretty amazing right and
so you can see it's pretty.
What does that picture
look like to you?
>> Dirty water.
>> Emily Williamson:
Yeah, a little dirty.
>> [Inaudible] recycle.
>> Emily Williamson: Yeah,
so there's some bottles there
at the bottom and the water doesn't
look particularly clean right?
So, we're going to learn about
that in the story as well.
And then this is a
photograph of a mine.
So, you can keep this in your
mind as we read the story as well.
So, Gizo-Gizo ends up
running a gold mine.
>> So you go under and
[inaudible] and dig out gold?
>> Emily Williamson: Some of them
are in tunnels and some of them are
above ground, they're all
different kinds of mines.
And so, this is the
community that I work with
and it's called a Zongo community
and its primarily Muslim.
So, you can see these are the houses
that the students that I worked
with on the book, that they live in.
And there's their mosque that they
go to every Friday for prayer.
And then water is also really
important in their religion,
so they wash, and they
pray five times a day
and they use these kettles.
So, they fill the kettles up
with water and then they wash.
Here's the little girl drinking
water, she helped on the book.
This is another picture,
so you can see
that they have open sewers
rather than pipes, okay.
And then this, guess what this.
>> A bathroom?
>> A school?
>> Emily Williamson: Yes,
so their school is outside,
and they actually string up
little tents, little canopies
and then they work under
those canopies in the shade.
So, when we wrote and
illustrated this book right here
and this is us working on the book.
[Inaudible children speaking
in unison] yeah that's me.
This is, [inaudible] yeah,
I've been there many times.
So that's me this is my friend
Catherine who helped on the book,
this is one of the teachers.
His name is Owl who says
hello to all of you today
and these are some of the students.
These are the kids
working on the story.
>> How old are the children?
>> Emily Williamson:
So, the children,
it's a huge age range can you guess
by looking at these photographs?
>> Four.
>> Eight.
>> Emily Williamson:
Four, good to what?
>> Six and five.
Emily Williamson: Six and five.
>> Eight.
>> Emily Williamson: Eight, so
the oldest child was sixteen
who was working on this story.
So, it was wonderful because the
younger children helped a lot
with the illustrations and
then the older kids tended
to enjoy the writing and,
so we worked together
and created this book
collaboratively.
So, there's some people, some of the
students like to work individually,
some just like to put their,
that's basically the equivalent
of their clipboard okay except
they can write directly on it.
So, he happens to be
balancing it on his head.
Some pictures of the students.
Everyone's very focused.
So, one thing I want to do at the
end of today's presentation is
to give you guys the opportunity
to also do a little bit of drawing
and to help us think
about a new story.
Okay, so I want to stop with
this one right now and I want
to read you the story and
then after I'm done reading,
what I would like to do
is a short art activity.
So, combining drawing and
writing about a character okay?
So, when I'm reading the story,
you can think about a character
that you might be interested
in drawing and writing about,
that maybe Gizo-Gizo meets okay?
Yeah so first though I'd
like to read the story.
Okay. Gizo-Gizo, a tale
from the Zongo Lagoon.
Okay, here's your opportunity
to learn a little more Hausa.
You ready?
So, I'm going to say it.
So, when I'm about to start a
story, I say Ga ta nan ga ta nanku.
And then, whoever's listening to
the story they say, tazo mujita.
>> [In unison] Tazo mujita.
>> Emily Williamson: Exactly,
saying we are all ears,
we're listening closely okay.
So, when I say ga ta nan ga ta
nanku, you say tazo mujita, okay?
Ready we'll try it, okay ready?
Ga ta nan ga ta nanku,
>> [In unison] Tazo mujita.
>> Emily Williamson:
I can't hear you.
Ga ta nan ga ta nanku.
>> [In unison] Tazo mujita.
>> Emily Williamson:
Okay, Gizo-Gizo,
a Tale from the Zango Lagoon.
Not so very long ago many
animals lived in the Zango Lagoon.
Fish bask in the clear clean waters,
frogs sang in the tall green
grasses, lizards scurried up
and down the trunks of
the leafy Moringa trees.
And down by the watery edge of
the peaceful lagoon that flowed
into the sea lived
three best friends.
Crab, Tortoise and Spider.
A fisherman by trade, Crab
was generous and hard-working.
He spent most of his time at the
bottom of the lagoon with his family
or hauling fish into his canoe.
Tortoise was wise and very patient.
Animals came to him for advice
and to buy the medicines he made
from the healing roots and leaves.
Unlike the other two,
Spider was lazy and selfish.
When he wasn't lounging around
in his favorite Moringa tree
overlooking the lagoon he
was mining for gold upstream
and dreamt of being rich.
Despite their differences,
Crab, Tortoise
and Spider ate dinner together
every day at high tide.
Crab caught the fish,
Tortoise blessed the kenkey
and Spider ate greedily.
One day after dinner, instead
of throwing his rubbish
into the dustbin, Spider
tossed his kenkey leaves
and plantain peels
right into the lagoon.
A boogie Crab pleaded using
the Hausa name for friend.
You must respect the lagoon,
it belongs to all of us.
Bagh Spider balked, a little
rubbish is no big deal.
I own a mining business,
someday when I am rich,
I will buy this place.
I can do whatever I want.
Rainy season came, and
Spider's bad habits grew worse.
He tossed his used water
sachets, empty mineral bottles,
and old rancid milk
right into the lagoon.
The water turned green and soupy
and no longer flowed into the sea.
The tall grasses were filthy
and smelly the banks
were muddy and bare.
Piles of garbage were everywhere.
Gizo-Gizo Crab begged, you
must respect the lagoon.
It belongs to all of us.
Ha! Spider bragged, my
mining business is booming.
A little rubbish is no big deal.
Someday when I am rich,
I will buy this place.
I can do whatever I want.
Dry season came, and Spiders
habits grew even worse!
His huge new factory
polluted the lagoon
with chemicals, oil, and waste.
The animals got sick, fish
groaned with empty stomachs,
frogs winced from sore throats,
lizards moaned from aching legs.
They all went to Tortoise and
asked for healing roots and leaves.
There was very little left.
Tortoise boiled the last of the
boozobo [phonetic spelling] flowers
to settle the fishes upset
stomachs, he pounded the last
of the Moringa leaves to
relieve the lizards aching legs.
He mixed the last of his
salt with clean water
to soothe the frog's sore throats.
Crab shook his head sadly and said,
this has gone on far too long.
We must talk some sense
into Spider's head.
The next day Crab and Tortoise
invited Spider to dinner.
His favorite meal of
fried fish and kenkay.
Look, he wrote a letter.
Dear Gizo-Gizo, you are invited
for fried fish and kenkay
for Saturday at high tide.
Crab and tortoise.
Spider sat down at the table and ate
greedily without so much as a glance
at his friends who
didn't eat one bite.
Little did Spider know, that
Crab had caught the fish
from the polluted Zango Lagoon
and that the kenkey was rotten.
Soon, Spider grew very ill.
His legs ache so badly he couldn't
climb down from his Moringa tree,
he tried to call two Tortoise for
help, but his throat was too sore.
He moaned and groaned
from his upset stomach.
Oh, what did I do?
Spider cried, I have
ruined our lagoon.
Crab and Tortoise smiled.
Perhaps Spider had
learned his lesson.
Gizo-Gizo, said Crab, there is only
one thing to do, you must clean
up the lagoon and never
dump rubbish into it.
Tortoise nodded wisely and added,
you must respect the lagoon
it belongs to all of us.
When Spider finally felt better,
he set to work busily
cleaning the lagoon.
He turned his mining business
into a place that cleaned water.
He collected rubbish from the
high grasses and removed the piles
of garbage from the basis
of the Moringa trees.
After many, many days of hard work,
fish basked at the
clear, clean waters.
Frog sang and the tall
green grasses.
Lizard scurried up and down the
trunks of the leafy Moringa trees.
Life was peaceful once
again in the Zango Lagoon.
So, Crab, Tortoise and Spider
enjoyed a dinner of fried fish
and kenkay together at high tide.
Crab caught the fish,
Tortoise blessed the meal
and Spider made an announcement.
I've learned my lesson, said
Spider to his old friends,
as my great-great grandfather used
to say, the lagoons water is sacred,
it belongs to no one and
everyone at the same time.
It takes only one day to destroy it
and many, many days to restore it.
We must keep it clean
every single day.
And then they end the story saying,
crun coos [phonetic
spelling] also in Hausa.
Do you want to say it?
Crun coos.
>> [In unison] Crun coos.
>> Emily Williamson: Perfect.
So that is the story and
I just want to say again
that this was a collaborative
effort.
So, that means that the students,
all of the students in Ghana worked
with me to do all of
these illustrations
and all of the writing.
So, we worked, we put our heads
together and created this story.
[inaudible audience question]
The students in Ghana, so a lot,
one student might have drawn
this house and another student
for example might have
drawn this fish
and then I helped put it together
and compose it on the page.
And so all of the students they
can recognize the different pieces
that they drew in the book.
Isn't that neat?
So that's a good transition and I
thought that we could take maybe 10
or 15 minutes thinking about,
so there are three main
elements of the story.
Does anyone know what the
three main elements are?
>> [Inaudible] the
tortoise and the Spider.
>> Emily Williamson:
Yes, okay great.
So, in this particular story,
the Spider, the Tortoise
and the Crab are the
main characters, right?
So, one element of a story
is creating characters.
Yep, you have another?
>> The main idea.
>> Emily Williamson: The main idea,
right okay the theme
of the story, right?
What the story is about.
So, this one is about
water and it's about mining
and keeping a lagoon clean.
>> It's about taking
care of the water.
>> Emily Williamson: It's about
taking care of the water exactly.
So that's another piece
of the story.
So, it's the action and
the theme are interrelated.
So, we have character,
we have action and theme,
and then what is the third one?
>> Teamwork.
>> Emily Williamson: Teamwork,
yes in this story this was a team,
this was a collaborative effort.
We worked as a team to create this
story and so then the third one
that I'm thinking of
that is also important
to the story, is the place, right?
In which it happened.
So, the setting, exactly and so
since we don't have
too much time today,
I thought we could
focus on a character.
So, I thought it would be fun, I
think we could pass the clipboards
around and if I could
actually have one
as a reference that
would be terrific.
Thank you.
Okay, so what we're thinking
when I was talking with students
in Ghana this past summer,
we thought it would be really
interesting to create a news story
about Gizo-Gizo, one
where he goes on a trip.
So, he's going to go on a journey
and I thought it would be fun
if we could think about characters
that Gizo-Gizo might
meet along his journey.
Who has an idea of a character
that Gizo-Gizo might
meet along a journey?
>> Another spider.
>> Emily Williamson: Another spider,
okay who else might he
meet on his journey?
>> Another Crab.
>> Emily Williamson: Another crab.
>> A bird.
>> Emily Williamson: A bird, okay.
>> A fish.
>> Emily Williamson: A fish, great.
>> A human [inaudible] a wolf.
>> Emily Williamson: A wolf, okay
so in addition to thinking either
about an animal or a
person, think about what kind
of personality they might have.
Are they a nice person?
Are they a lazy person or animal?
What kind?
Are they stubborn?
Are they clever?
Are they wise?
And what that might mean.
So I'd like you to write
your name at the top,
and then if you have any questions
that you want to ask a student
in Ghana, I left you a little
space there so if there's something
that you want to share about
your character or anything,
any kind of question that you have
about the story, I will do my best
to get answers for you so you can
talk to the students in Ghana.
And then in the center of the page,
you can draw your character okay.
And I'm going to pass around
some examples of characters
that other students in Ghana have
drawn and then in these bubbles
around the character that you draw,
you can describe it using words
or if you'd rather just draw in
these bubbles you can do that too.
So, here it says my
character looks like,
so you could just add some words
that describe what your
character looks like.
My character likes to say, so maybe
your character has a specific phrase
he or she likes to say, like son
ooh [phonetic spelling] who knows?
It could be an English or in
Hausa or in another language.
My character's personalities,
you can describe that.
My character thinks about, so what
is your character dream about?
What do they like to do?
So, you can fill these in
however you like and if you'd
like to just draw in the
center that's fine too.
I just want this to be a
fun exercise and then I want
to take your drawings with me to
Ghana and share them with kids there
and I'm hoping that maybe all
together we can create a story.
What do you think about that?
Yeah, do you have a question?
>> Did you write that book?
>> Emily Williamson: I did, with
students in Ghana it was teamwork.
What do you think?
Anyone else have any question?
[Inaudible comments]
So, I'm going to just pass around
so you can see, I'm going to kind
of lay these out actually,
not for you to copy
but just to get some ideas.
These are some drawings
that the kids have done.
I don't know, what
do you think it is?
I think they made it up
in their imagination.
So, it doesn't have to be a real
animal either it can be something
you make up, anything you like.
So, these are just to
give you some ideas.
Yeah, sure that would be great.
If anyone wants to talk through
a character idea I'm happy
to walk around and help.
These are some personalities, so
you can just, if they're helpful,
you can think about them.
Oh, you want it?
I think someone else has it.
I think Sasha's coming.
[Inaudible question] So this
is a, [inaudible question] yes,
so this is in Hausa
and this is an English.
So, this character feels
anxious and this is wise, evil.
Just to give you some ideas.
Do you have an idea?
My character looks like a Crab.
Nice that's great.
Do you want to draw the crab?
Do you have a name for your crab?
>> The Good Crab.
>> Emily Williamson: Is it
a female or a male crab?
Okay.
>> Dami.
>> Emily Williamson: Dami?
I like that, that's
a beautiful name.
You could even put that
on there if you want too.
Where does your character live?
>> She lives in New York.
>> Emily Williamson: Oh
cool, you want to add that?
That's great.
I love your crab.
Nice, beautiful.
Oh, that's great, Cutie Pie.
My character has pink
and blue hair, long hair.
Oh, that's wonderful.
What is your character's
name and where do they live?
>> Oh wow!
Great. Nice.
I love this.
Yeah so what is this crab like?
Is he nice?
Is he mean?
Is he clever?
Is he shy?
So sometimes these are helpful too.
Oh look, so this one
jealous, is he jealous?
Maybe not, nope.
>> He's nice.
>> Emily Williamson: He's
nice, yeah so how is he nice?
What does he like to
do that makes him nice?
[Inaudible response] Yeah,
that's good, that's good.
So maybe he does things
to help his friends.
So, everybody, I think
it's time to wrap up.
But before we turn them
in, does anyone want
to share their character?
Let's do three shares.
I think we have time for three.
So, you could just tell us a
little bit about your character.
>> My character is a
cheetah caterpillar
and he like to say rich and he.
>> Emily Williamson: Wow
wonderful, fantastic.
Anyone else?
>> My character is a
unicorn and she want to fly.
>> Emily Williamson: Great, okay.
>> My character is a
butterfly and she is kind
as she wants to be more kind.
>> Emily Williamson: Wonderful
alright okay let's do two more.
>> My character is a girl and she's
smart, intelligent, she's beautiful,
and she's warm-hearted inside.
>> Emily Williamson:
Great, okay one more.
>> My character is about
a little boy who is rich.
>> Okay, great thank you so much.
So, we'll collect the clipboards
and I'm going to make sure that all
of the students in Ghana get
to see these amazing characters
that you created, and I think
we should all stay in touch
and hopefully we can create a
collaborative story together.
So now I think I just
wanted to open it up to,
if you all have any
questions for me?
Or if you have questions for the
kids and I can write them down
and ask them when I see them next.
I'm going to be going
back there next summer.
You're done?
Perfect, thank you.
>> How many students are there?
>> Emily Williamson: That is
a great question, so every,
I have been doing this for many,
many years and I started in 2012
and we had about thirty students and
then it went up to about forty-five.
In 2014 and last year, we started
a very large educational program
with many kids in the
capital city called Accra
and we had almost a
hundred students.
>> What's like, your type
of books, like does it have,
like a meant to it like for
their characters to change it,
the kind of the middle
and the ends of the story?
Or is there like different
ways you make it?
>> Emily Williamson: Would
you mind rephrasing or,
so did the character
change throughout the story?
>> Like how their emotions changed
when he thought he could rule it
but then he figures out
that he needs to take care
to make it a better place.
>> Emily Williamson:
Exactly, exactly, so,
so much about stories is
about character development
and characters changing
right and learning a lesson
or learning something
about themselves.
And so, in this story, Gizo-Gizo
changed throughout the course
of the story, right?
Exactly.
>> What do they eat?
>> Emily Williamson:
What do they eat?
That is a great question.
So, in Ghana there
are all kinds of food.
I think I heard one
student say before the name
of a food called fufu.
Does anyone know what fufu is?
>> Fufu is something
that comes from Africa.
>> Emily Williamson: Yes, it's
a food that comes from Africa,
does anyone know what fufu is?
>> Potatoes or [inaudible]
>> Emily Williamson: So,
>> I eat it.
>> Emily Williamson:
You eat it okay?
So fufu it's kind of
like this big ball of,
it almost looks like pizza dough.
But it's made of something called
cassava which is like a yam
or like a particular kind of like a
potato, but dry and then they mix it
with something called plantain,
which is kind of like a banana
and they pound it and they pound
it forever and then it turns
into a big ball of basically kind of
dough and then you eat it with soup.
It's very delicious and very heavy.
>> She doesn't pound it, she
just like, use something,
she makes it in the oven,
she mixes it in the oven.
>> Emily Williamson: Oh wow,
I need to learn from your mom.
That's great, so fufu is a very,
very popular food and if you speak
to almost any Guiana and they will
say that fufu is their favorite.
[Laughter] Yes, jollof
rice also very popular
which is a spicy rice
with vegetables in it.
>> What's the food that
you mentioned in your book?
>> Emily Williamson: So,
the food that I mentioned
in the book is called kenkay
and it's fermented corn,
and then they wrap it in a corn
leaf or in a, sorry, in a palm leaf.
And they often will sell them
in huge piles along the side
of the road and you can just
kind of peel it open and eat it.
So, they don't even use plastic
bags or anything or any kind
of plastic to keep it safe.
They just use palm leaves.
Anyone else?
>> Are there any beaches in Ghana?
>> Emily Williamson: There are,
there are a lot of beaches.
So, she asked if there any beaches
in Ghana and yes there are a lot
of really beautiful beaches.
The shores are also quite
rocky in a lot of areas
and the tide is very strong,
so you need to be careful
when you go swimming.
I have only been swimming
once in Ghana
but yes there are gorgeous beaches.
>> Anyone else?
>> What are beaches?
>> Emily Williamson:
What are beaches?
Who knows what a beach is?
So, it's a sandy edge
along a coastline.
>> Yeah, and salt water.
>> Yeah, it's like a whole ocean.
>> An ocean with sand.
>> Emily Williamson: An
ocean with sand, yeah.
So, in Hausa, the word
for beach is bakin teku
which means the mouth of the ocean.
Anyone else?
>> Are beaches in Ghana
the same as beaches in DC?
Is the beach the same
as in Maryland?
>> Emily Williamson: The
beaches are very similar yes.
So, the question was are the beaches
in Ghana similar to
those in Maryland?
Yes, I think they are.
They're very similar.
And they're both on
the Atlantic Ocean.
They kind of face each other it
would be a long way to get from one
to the other but, they're
very similar.
>> Is the beaches colder
in Maryland?
>> Emily Williamson:
Oh, is the water colder?
>> The water.
>> Emily Williamson: So, the water
is probably a little bit warmer
than in Maryland but it's
because, so the weather is very,
very tropical and very,
very humid in Ghana.
>> Are the waves bigger there?
>> Emily Williamson: Wow so many
questions about the beaches.
[Laughter] I think we
all want to go swimming.
You know, in some areas the waves
are very, very big and because it's
so rocky, the waves hit the
rocks and bounce off the rocks
and go really high into the air.
So, it can also be a
little bit dangerous.
>> Is Ghana [inaudible]
>> Emily Williamson: Is?
>> Is Ghana big?
>> Emily Williamson: Is Ghana big?
So, let's see, so I'm
trying to think.
So, in a car if you were driving
from the beach all the way
up to the north of
Ghana, it's probably going
to take you about 20 hours.
So, it's almost like driving from
here up to northern New Hampshire.
>> If you walk, what happens?
>> Emily Williamson:
One more question.
Okay one more.
We have time for one more question.
>> If you walk over
there how much hours?
>> Emily Williamson: Oh my
gosh, we better start now.
[Laughter] and I'm not
sure we could walk there.
I think we would need
to build a boat first.
Okay, thank you so much everybody.
So, who remembers how
to say hello in Hausa?
So, if I say, sannu
you say, yowah sannu.
So, and then in Hausa, to say,
if I want to say thank you
to all of you, I say na gode.
>> Na gode
>> Emily Williamson: Na gode.
So, thank you so much.
Na gode.
>> Na gode.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov